[Musique]
régis saint-val bonjour bonjour monsieur
livory bonjour la martinique
bonjour les auditeurs de martin est
première et l'évoqué noah évoque ténoise
alors monsieur saint-val vous avez 52
ans vous avez trois enfants vous êtes
technicien l'éducation nationale et vous
allez mener la liste osons l'avenir pour
le vauclin c'est ça c'est ça qu'est ce
qui vous motive c'est votre première
participation à une élection aux
municipales au vauclin municipal
vauquelin oui tout à fait alors qu'est
ce qui vous motive
qu'est ce qui me motive
régis saint-val candidat à l'élection
municipale au vauclin je vais dire que
le voeckler avant tout c'est là où je
suis ni donc je suive au quesnoy
je vis au vauclin et le cac gpo le
vauclin mais c'est pour cela que
aujourd'hui je suis candidat aux
municipales
du coup vous êtes revenu en martinique
depuis novembre
novembre 2010 9,1 là il ya quelques mois
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
connaître la commune alors je le précise
un jeu ça fait plus de dix ans que je
faisais là l'aller retour sur le la
martinique et plus précisément au
vauclin j'ai ma maison au vauclin et je
vis au vauclin mais ce que vous qu'est
ce que pour vous c'est suffisant tout ça
parce que entre passé des années revenir
en vacances la commune change les choses
changent et changent évoluent les choses
évoluent est ce que si suffisant
aujourd'hui pour se présenter
alors oui je sais c'est suffisant
puisque depuis en france je travaillais
en collaboration avec quelques personnes
basées sur le vauclin et de jour en jour
je me tenais informé sur les différentes
positions et ils ferment de choses qui
se faisait sur la commune du vauclin si
on devait vous situer sur l'échiquier
politique parce qu'on fait on fait
connaissance au niveau en apprendre à
vous connaître
on vous situez où exactement doigt de
gauche centre vous êtes vous alors je
suis de gauche je suis de gauche
voilà d'accord vous êtes soutenu par un
parti vous avez un parti qui vous
soutient non je ne suis pas encarté et
c'est pour cela que la liste osons
l'avenir pour le vauclin c'est une liste
plurielle qui fait que nous avons
rassemblé toutes les forces et toutes
les volontés en vue de travailler pour
le vauclin donc je le dis aux en
l'avenir
c'est travailler pour le vauclin c'est
difficile de monter une liste
il vous faut combien de colistiers ou
alors il faut il faut 28 plus
le maire et qui est devant aujourd'hui
régis savane d'accord il faut en 29 29
personnes sur la liste air sont à parité
vous arriver avant tout à monter votre
liste eh bien écoutez je pense que nous
sommes en bonne voie
on travaille on travaille puisque nous
avons sillonné les 48 quartier est ce
qui fait un bain au fur et à mesure et
la loi me permet jusqu'au 27 d'avoir la
liste enfin pour pouvoir poursuivre
notre mission
d'accord quel constat faites vous de la
situation du foot lui aujourd'hui
comment quel constat vous faites du
travail effectué par le maire sortant
qui ne se représente pas d'ailleurs le
maire partant le meilleur partant et
quels constats et bien je pense que par
rapport à la communication que aux ans à
venir a instauré sur la commune du
vauclin puisque nous avons rencontré pas
mal de personnes est le constat en tout
cas pour ma part les structures sont
vieillissants donc il faut se pencher
dessus
nous avons aussi l'aménagement
comme je vous le dis l'aménagement du
territoire où nous avons des
propositions à faire sur la commune du
vauclin
quelles propositions veut un programme
d'aménagement qu'est ce que vous
entendez par là alors l'aménagement
c'est à dire prévenir pour mieux avancer
parce que bon si vous voulez un exemple
un exemple typique au niveau du vauclin
la population s'est agrandie et les
sculptures neu neu neu neu neu ne
suivent pas donc il va falloir se
pencher sur la question d'assainissement
sur le voeckler et quand je parle aussi
de l'aménagement
d'après les quartiers qu'on a visités
sur le vauclin quartier labroue là ils
sont en attente de travaux un pont qui a
été emmenée par l'ailé les eaux les au
nez on a aussi le parcours de santé l'a
aussi payé un abandon et un abandon et
c'est un peu
risqué pour les ceux qui fréquentent ya
un thème qui revient souvent au vauclin
se sont laissé la gestion du foncier la
gestion des terres vous avez quelque
chose sur sa la gestion du foncier on
accuse souvent de l'ancien maire d'avoir
un peu dilapidé les terres qu'est ce que
votre votre position sur ça alors ma
position est claire et simple je crois
que nous avons une jeunesse au vauclin
qui a besoin et non pas seulement la
jeunesse mais je veux dire que les veaux
clean wahou besoin de rester au frais
les blaireaux kinois ont besoin
d'investir sur le vauclin et par
conséquent quand je vois la vente de
terrains de 2 15 euros
et alors qu'en campagne on les vend à
40,50 euros
là il faut se poser des questions osons
l'avenir je pense allait proposer autre
chose c'est-à-dire de 2,2 de construire
des locaux et pouvoir accueillir les
artisans et les professionnels au
vauclin voilà ça fait plus de cinq
minutes monsieur régis saint-val je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]